told her that I was dead and that she
needed to stay in bed and wait until the
police come
he then went and found the police and
told them that you killed me
and that he needed to be taken away
this is a story about how a survivor of
domestic violence confronted her abuser
and moved on with her life through a
process called the restorative justice
I've been finding out what restorative
justice actually is how it's being used
in the UK and why many victims are not
being offered it sure sure I think
restorative justice is obviously very
appropriate for a whole range of other
crimes but in those crimes most of the
time
there's not that relationship and the
ongoing potential for abuse that you
have with domestic abuse
start to justice is essentially about
communication after a crime has taken
place it provides an opportunity for
those harmed by the offense to put
across their views about what happened
the impact they had on them the
potentially asked questions to the one
person that can really only answer those
questions
you've been a victim of a crime it could
be a burglary or an assault on a night
out your perpetrator gets convicted and
sent to prison
but why did they do it and are they
really sorry or will they come for you
again one day
restorative justice as a way of bringing
perpetrator together with the victim to
get answers and perhaps some closure
it's up to each police and crime
commissioning area to decide how much to
spend on the service and for domestic
violence victims it's particularly
controversial you know if for example I
think most people think oh when you
leave an abuser the abuse must stop well
actually that's when your risk increases
and so and and perpetrators of abuse
will do absolutely anything to try to
continue that connection
you tell me exactly what happened to you
um I was a victim of domestic violence I
had a
fallen in love who with a man that I'd
seen over a packed High Street it was
love at first sight for us
um but the relationship was toxic on all
levels we both um had drink problems
to this day I've still got no
recollection of the actual attack itself
and the only witness was my daughter and
she was eight years old at the time
um she had heard some commotion in the
bedroom
and then had asked my ex-partner
um what was going on why I couldn't come
in and tuck her in good night she knew
that something was
seriously wrong and he told her that I
was dead and that she needed to stay in
bed and wait until the police come
he then went and found the police and
told them that you killed me and that he
needed to be taken away
um wasn't until a porter was taking me
for some more x-rays or scans that he
had ruled me in the wheelchair
frontwards into the lift and then he
said oh I was meant to bring you in
backwards so I seen myself on the
mirrored bit that goes around
um in the lift and honestly I just
looked like the Elephant Man I was
barely recognized myself
um
and he had beaten me with a large pepper
grinder until he thought I was dead so
my injuries were quite significant
and so began a long and lonely process
of going to court and getting him
convicted but Lucy's experience left her
with far more questions than answers
that in those interim years so you
basically he had been convicted
and you were left feeling what's going
to happen to me he's going to come out
am I going to see him again like yeah
how did that feel for you
um I had to move home
um because it was deemed too unsafe to
me to stay where I was my daughter would
have become a child at risk so we had to
move and I become completely isolated
from everyone I knew
everything that was safe and my mental
health just spiraled and spiraled
um further and further out of control
until I was just at home on my own
a wreck really I barely go out of my
bedroom
um
and then I I fought back
I managed to get myself clean and sober
and I thought I I need to be able to do
something I need to be able to speak to
him or write a letter or or do something
to be able to put the past behind me and
to be able to move on
um I contacted my Victim liaison officer
he said how do you fancy meeting him
face to face
um
and I said yeah it's that even possible
not knowing how difficult it is for
um
victims of domestic violence to get
access to restorative justice
the day of the conference
I was nervous
I was nervous about how the whole thing
would go
when we got into the prison as soon as I
walked into the room
and I saw him sitting there
it reminded me that he is just one
person just one normal average person
not this all-consuming
um Dark Cloud that had
shadowed my life for so long
um
in that moment
I got my perspective back
um we had our chat when I left the
conference
I it sounds cheesy I felt like I had
been reborn that I'd got my power back
that it was honestly the first day of
the rest of my life I don't know where I
would be had I've not had that
conference
if I'd not had that face-to-face meeting
because he has been released from prison
but I have no anxiety about that
what are your
Festus could have a role in domestic
violence cases
well I suppose my overarching view is
with a lot of caution
um you know I'm aware that you've
spoken with a couple of victims and
survivors who really feel this has
worked for them and I I would never wish
to deny that experience I think that's
really important I think we have to be
really careful about knowing what works
exactly what that means you know what
kind of training
Assessments in place it's just simply
not the kind of thing that we could do
without that without a great deal of
caution planning and
more research you know to know exactly
who's doing this what are they actually
doing
how are they following up there is some
evidence to show restorative justice can
have a positive impact but it's limited
a 2021 report by restorative Services
provided remedy found that 94 of victims
of all crime types felt their sense of
safety increased after going through the
process
a 2013 study from the U.S showed half
the number of convicted domestic
violence offenders were reconvicted if
they'd been through the restorative
justice process
a 2007 report commissioned by the UK
government found that restorative
justice has an 85 satisfaction rate for
victims
but with so little evidence focusing on
the impact on domestic violence cases
some Charities have major concerns I
think it's incredibly important to
listen to the needs and the experiences
of survivors but equally I think it is
extremely difficult even for the most
skilled and trained professional to
really understand the motivation for the
perpetrator to go into the process and
to be able to keep the Survivor safe
during the process as well
Natasha's former partner is in prison
convicted of raping and sexually
assaulting her she is one of the vast
majority of women who experience the
justice system in the conventional way
with no further contact with their
perpetrator for me I don't need closure
by talking to my abuser again the things
that he did I don't need answers for
they're they're on him they're not on me
and I think it's it's very much uh
I think excuses can be made abusers
frequently lie that's what they do they
lie and they manipulate and I think
giving them the opportunity to not only
manipulate their victims more and put
them back at risk but I think there's
also that huge risk of professionals
being manipulated by that and their
judgment being skewed by false promises
Good Girl drop it drop it
drop it good girl the criminal justice
system tends to be very bulky and very
um you know one size fits all when one
size clearly doesn't fit all and that's
what we're struggling with people saying
on one hand it's it's working for some
that the idea of I guess My worry is
taking that without a huge amount of
evidence and then offering that in a
much larger scale would you know we
would really want to pull back and and
do that with a lot more caution more
resource you know we have a very
under-resourced criminal justice system
I wanted to get an idea of how many of
these cases were actually progressing
seeing as there were so many concerns
I asked all of the police and crime
commissioning areas how many domestic
violence cases had gone through the
restorative justice process in the past
year
of those who responded while none said
they excluded domestic abuse cases their
numbers were very low
in West Mercier which covers Shropshire
Telford and reckon and Worcestershire
they had never used restorative justice
for a case of domestic abuse
the lack of proper guidelines and
research seems to be a major roadblock
here
I asked practitioner Nicola how her work
was affected
there are challenges for us as an
organization in progressing restorative
justice in domestic use cases because
there's not a consistency in each area
that we work in terms of the partner
agency acceptance that this could be
explored and certainly from a Ministry
of Justice perspective there are no
National guidance around the delivery of
restorative justice and domestic abuse
cases
we've developed our own framework which
is very robust and it's been tested and
trialled and and certainly had input
from our partner agencies where we've
developed it but it would be really
um beneficial for us if there was that
National guidance in place from a
Ministry of Justice
the ministry of Justice told me it's
taking steps to ensure every victim no
matter the crime involved is offered the
opportunity to take part in restorative
justice although it won't be appropriate
for all cases
it said funding for victim and witness
Support Services will reach 192 million
pounds a year by 2024. some of which
will go to police and crime
Commissioners to commission local
support services for victims of all
crime types
we also approached the National Police
Chiefs Council and the association of
police and crime commissioners
they say they've begun working on
developing a national strategy on
restorative justice including how that
will apply to domestic violence cases
I guess when I think about the criminal
justice system and domestic abuse and I
think there's so many more fundamental
things that we have to prioritize just
getting things right end to end making
sure that victims are getting the
justice that they deserve and need and I
think restorative justice is kind of on
on the map for that but I do I it
wouldn't be my first priority in terms
of the kind of route and branch
you know reform we need of the criminal
justice system for issues like domestic
abuse it's clear that wider reform is
needed in the justice system without
significant investment and research
restorative justice for domestic
violence victims will continue to be
difficult to access
but for Lucy I'm left wondering where
she would be without it
as much as I'd like to think that I
could keep it together sitting in your
bedroom terrified of your own shadow not
answering the door having the TV on mute
that's about as low as it can get
um and restorative justice has given me
the freedom to now be here
I never went
to the conference expecting to be able
to forgive him it was not on my radar I
didn't really care about his feelings or
how he felt
but it happened and it just happened
naturally naturally I did forgive him
and I needed to do that to be able to
let the anger and the fear and
and the Panic that he had caused me I
needed to be able to let that go yes
I've forgiven him for what he's done
um
I just hope he doesn't do it to anybody
else